it finally happened chapter 400 of mha
brings us the Epic climax of the battle
to the death between all might and all
for one all might is dying all for one
is a toddler and then that insane twist
at the end we waited so long for this to
happen and now it's finally here so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy rmha videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now to help
us out with that YouTube algorithm and
if you want to see this channel finally
awaken its Quirk by hitting 2 million
subscribers Please Subscribe right now
huge thank you to Code Geass lost
stories for sponsoring this video man
I'm so excited to tell you guys about
this video sponsor because I absolutely
love Code Geass it's literally in my top
5 anime of all time but I've already
watched and re-watched kodias many times
if only there was a new story set within
that world that I could a part of that
is what I've been waiting for and that
is exactly what Code Geass lost stories
provides Code Geass law stories is a
tower defense strategy game that remains
extremely faithful to the Code Geass
World while allowing you to enter that
world as an ally of a luge who
participates directly in lelouch's Epic
plans and activities you can literally
make your own team and add your favorite
characters like Lelouch C2 and Colin to
that team I can finally become one of
the Black Knights just like I've always
wanted the game features original voice
actors from the anime Beautiful live 2D
animation Vivid combat effects and it
even allows you to engage in intense and
strategic Mech battles with 3D
animations Yes you heard that right you
get to Pilot an actual nightmare frame
you get to take part in the main story
while also doing daily quests
Expeditions challenge quests and limited
time events all within the world of Code
Geass this is honestly my Code Geass
nerd dream come true so do yourself a
favor and try it out for yourself right
now Link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so in the last chapter the ever
young girl all for one promised that the
entire world was about to watch the
death of the symbol of peace in real
time all might didn't let this get to
him though he simply said that if his
own light were to be extinguished right
here and now the next generation of
Heroes including Deku and all might
other students would inherit his light
and use it to illuminate the darkness
even if the old symbol of peace were to
Die the next generation of Heroes would
take up the torch and become the new
symbols of peace even if all might
sacrifices his life in this battle his
will and his legacy will live on through
his students all of this was of course
heavily foreshadowing all might's
imminent death and a lot of us were
getting very nervous about how this
battle would ultimately end for our boy
toshinori the previous chapter also
showed us the fight between a bunch of
other Heroes and the piranha plant
villain cunieda fat gum was there along
with aoyamam and others and eventually
toru hagakura appeared and worked
together with aoyama to take the villain
out as toru refracted ayama's Naval
laser right into kunieta she slowly
started becoming visible which provided
us with an extremely rare glimpse of
Toto's true appearance and how she
really looks when she's fighting well it
was a rare Glimpse up to this point at
least because things are about to change
back in the fight between all might and
all for one a severely injured omai
declared that he still believes that he
will win as he used what was left to
Hercules to fire a gigantic laser beam
right at all for one it is a laser beam
attack that was inspired by aoyama the
hero who can't stop twinkling the latest
chapter chapter 400 starts off in the
aftermath of the fight against kunietta
and can you believe that we are already
400 chapters into this series that is
insane as Toto sits on top of the
villain pinning him to the ground I am a
Caesar and toru then realizes that she
is visible meaning that how am I seeing
her completely without clothes upon
realizing what's happening toru
immediately screams and her face turns
red she tries to cover herself up with
her arms and then she runs into the
woods to hide toru is confused because
nothing like this has ever happened
before she is normally always invisible
and as we know so are both of her
parents so we can assume that toru has
never had to worry about being seen
without clothes because she never had to
worry about being seen at all Toto does
remember that when she first uncovered
the truth about ayama being a traitor
her face suddenly became partially
visible Toto believes that her Quirk has
begun to glitch and this glitch could be
related to facing extremely stressful
situations and risking her life on the
battlefield but although total may not
realize it yet she may be actually
undergoing a quirk Evolution and or
Awakening some thing that has been a
major theme in this final Arc of the
story ochako's Quirk recently awakened
todoroki's Quirk evolved when he
unlocked phosphor coda's Quirk became
stronger Tokyo aminita's quirks became a
lot stronger and even villains like toga
and Dobby underwent Quirk Awakenings at
various points in the story so toru's
Quirk may be evolving to the point that
she can just decide to turn her
invisibility off and on toru also points
out that ayama's laser Quirk has now
become stronger so there is a consistent
theme here about quirk's evolving
especially in critically important life
or death situations we've known about
deku's Quirk Awakening and evolution for
a very long time but now in the final
Arc those same themes of Quirk Evolution
and Awakening are being applied to the
other class 1a students aoyama then
reminds toru that their job isn't done
yet Kuni Ada may have been defeated but
his deadly plans could still be
dangerous if they are not destroyed so
they have to destroy them all hayama
tells total to use her light powers to
burn the roots that have been implanted
into the bodies of the heroes by the
villain and he vows to give it his all
to be a good hero today even if his
stomach hurts from overusing his Quirk
he will push through it today he will go
all out because today is his final day
as a UA student after this cryptic Doom
posting by aoyama the chapter takes us
back to the big fight between all might
and all for one we pick up right where
we left off in the last chapter with
Hercules still firing that giant laser
right into all for one from above all
might quickly jumps out of the way in
order to avoid being hit by the massive
laser blast a blast that has seemingly
incinerated an entire Street like it was
nothing and it's still going on this
laser wasn't just like a quick one-time
blast it is a steady stream of laser
energy that continues to hit all for one
and pin him to the ground doing enormous
damage to his body in the process all
might strategy of attacking all all for
one with an overwhelmingly powerful
laser attack in order to disrupt his
regeneration abilities was inspired by
all for one's fight against star and
strike and so all might is now paying
tribute to yet another hero who looked
up to him as a mentor and he is sending
a clear message to all for one and to us
the readers star's death wasn't in vain
because due to her battle with the
villain almight was able to learn
valuable lessons for ultimately
defeating all for one at this point over
one has been literally driven into the
ground by the laser but he is trying to
crawl out almight then hits him with a
sound based attack based on earphone
jack and this prevents the villain from
escaping we also learned that the reason
why all might wasn't affected by the
laser even though it landed very close
to him is because his suit also has an
ability based on toru's refraction and
this allowed him to minimize the damage
to himself in addition he used an
ability inspired by tailman to reduce
the impact of all for one's attack so as
you can see all might is just basically
running down the list of all the class
1a student quirks in this fight
horikoshi really wants us to know how
much these students mean to all might
and how much he respects their quirks
and their abilities as all for one
launches multiple tendrils at all might
the hero somehow combines Momos and
minata's Quirk to turn parts of his
armor into large balls that stick to all
for one's hands and glue them to the
ground it's important to remember that
as all of this is happening that laser
is still hitting all for one so the
longer he stays in that spot the more
damage he is taking at this point all
might and his armor look to be in
terrible shape and yet the hero is still
laughing and he is still fighting in
some other country a small boy is
watching the fight on the TV he and his
grandma don't know much about this hero
who lives on the other side of the world
but almight's smile and his tenacity win
the young boy over and it's clear that
he is hoping that all might will win
this one boy is just a single example of
what is surely happening with millions
of people around the world they are
watching this fight on TV they are
seeing How brave omit is how he keeps
fighting Against All Odds how he keeps
smiling and laughing through the pain
and they want to root for him eventually
the part of Hercules that is firing the
laser overheats and explodes and all for
one is finally freed he now looks maybe
a little older than a toddler and a
strange light seems to be coming from
his body bruh is all for one the
original luminescent baby or did he
maybe Jack the luminescent baby's Quirk
at some point we'll have to wait and see
all might continues mocking the villain
and he now calls him a Rugrat but with
the terrible shape that the hero is
currently in he's almost certainly going
to die all for one might be a child but
he is still incredibly strong and full
of overpowered quirks while all might is
barely standing just as all for one is
about to unleash a brutal final attack
on all might he suddenly realizes that
he cannot move he is paralyzed the
villain doesn't know what's happening
but he quickly realizes what just
happened after all this time everyone's
favorite anti-hero stain has finally
arrived stain says everyone's blood is
equally red this is what causes all for
one to become paralyzed it is the result
of stain's Quirk and in the final panel
of this chapter stain screams out go all
might and that's it that is how the
chapter ends this was freaking awesome
just when it looked like that all mine
had given it his all and that this was
about to end stain finally makes his
return the return that we've all been
waiting for and of course he chooses to
help almight not the villains if you've
been watching my videos then you know
how many times I've mentioned stained
and how many times I've wondered when he
is finally going to enter the fight on
the side of the heroes and that is
finally happening right now with all for
one quickly turning into to a literal
baby perhaps all mine and staying
together can actually take him out but
does that mean that all mine could
actually survive or has he already been
fatally injured and we just don't know
it yet what else is stain going to do in
this fight could his Quirk also awaken
in some way and if he helps all might
win will he call it a day or will he try
to help Deku as well we can assume that
all might even if he survives will be in
no shape to do any more fighting so Deku
will still be against shigaraki on his
own is all for one actually the first
person to ever get a quirk is he
secretly the luminescent baby Will
horikoshi Survive another onslaught of
criticism on Twitter after those total
panels let me know down below if you
guys enjoy my amateur videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like right now and if you want to
help this channel awaken its Quirk by
hitting 2 million subscribers don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell subscribing is
completely free but it helps me out a
lot thanks again to code of the
Rebellion lost stories for sponsoring
this video check them out Link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys